but we begin with where we stand today
this is a track of cases just this week
there are now more than 14,000 reported
cases in the u.s. nearly quadruple the
total on Monday the death toll has
climbed to at least 205 people
California is now under a statewide
stay-at-home order the first state to
take that step here's what governor
Gavin Newsom had to say last night
there's a recognition of our
interdependence that requires of this
moment that we direct a statewide order
for people to stay at home let's bend
the curve together
let's not regret let's not dream of
regretting go back say well you know we
coulda woulda should have California is
the most populous state in America it's
also the world's fifth largest economy
Jamie yuccas joins us from Los Angeles
Jamie what does it look like where you
are well Anthony I am currently standing
on the iconic Ventura Boulevard here in
Los Angeles and you can see not many
cars around me right now and normally
this time of day there would be some
traffic governor Newsom will keep
essential businesses open that means
things like banks also grocery stores
where you can see there's some
deliveries being made this morning they
also will keep open pharmacies and here
in California
that also means marijuana dispensaries
will stay open as well as take out
restaurants but other things like
furniture stores barber shops record
stores those types of things that you
see up and down the boulevard they will
all be closed
Newsom said the decision comes as
California plans for a worst case
scenario where 56 percent of the state's
residents contract coronavirus that's
more than 22 million people officials
believe that could lead to more than
19,000 people in the hospital which
would overwhelm current capacity but the
governor says that this stay at home
order is meant to starve off those
worst-case-scenario numbers and by the
way if you don't shelter in place and
stay at home you could face a
misdemeanor which means also a fine Tony
Jamie thank you very much